Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Penny Martínez
En la década de 1950,
el descubrimiento de dos nuevos fármacos
creó un mercado multimillonario
de antidepresivos.
Ninguno de ellos estaba destinado
al tratamiento de la depresión:
de hecho, muchos médicos y científicos
creían entonces que la psicoterapia
era el único método
para tratar la depresión.
El recorrido de décadas
de descubrimientos que siguió
revolucionó nuestro
entendimiento de la depresión
y planteó preguntas
que no habíamos considerado antes.
Uno de esos primeros antidepresivos
fue la iproniazida,
un fármaco para el tratamiento
de la tuberculosis.
En una prueba de 1952,
no sólo curó la tuberculosis,
sino que mejoró el ánimo de los pacientes,
que habían sido diagnosticados
previamente con depresión.
En 1956, un médico suizo notó un efecto
similar al realizar un ensayo
de imipramina, un fármaco
para las reacciones alérgicas.
Ambos fármacos afectaron a un tipo
de neurotransmisores: las monoaminas.
El descubrimiento
de esos fármacos antidepresivos
dio auge a la teoría
del desequilibrio químico,
a la idea de que la depresión es causada
por una insuficiencia de monoaminas
en las sinapsis del cerebro.
Se cree que la iproniazida, la imipramina
y otros fármacos parecidos
restauran ese equilibrio,
al aumentar la disponibilidad
de monoaminas en el cerebro.
Estos fármacos se dirigen
a diversas monoaminas,
que actúan en un amplio
rango de receptores del cerebro.
A menudo esto implica
muchos efectos secundarios,
como dolores de cabeza,
náuseas, disfunción cognitiva
y dificultades con la memoria,
el pensamiento y el juicio.
Con el deseo de hacer
los fármacos más efectivos
y de reducir los efectos secundarios
los científicos empezaron a estudiar
los antidepresivos existentes
para hallar qué monoaminas
específicas estaban más asociadas
con mejoras en la depresión.
En la década de 1970,
varios investigadores diferentes
concordaron en una respuesta:
los antidepresivos más efectivos
parecían actuar sobre una sola monoamina:
la serotonina.
Ese descubrimiento llevó a la producción
de fluoxetina, o Prozac, en 1988.
Fue el primero
de una nueva clase de fármacos
llamados Inhibidores Selectivos
de la Recaptación de Serotonina, o ISRS,
que bloquean la reabsorción
de la serotonina,
dejando más disponible en el cerebro.
Prozac funcionó bien
y tuvo menos efectos secundarios
que los antidepresivos
anteriores menos efectivos.
Los fabricantes de Prozac trabajaron
a su vez en comercializar el fármaco,
creando conciencia
sobre los peligros de la depresión
tanto para el público
como para la comunidad médica.
Más gente llegó a ver
la depresión como una enfermedad
causada por mecanismos
más allá del control del individuo,
lo que redujo la cultura de la culpa y
la estigmatización entorno a la depresión,
y más gente buscó ayuda.
En la década de 1990,
el número de personas
que recibió tratamiento
por depresión se disparó.
La psicoterapia y otros tratamientos
se quedaron en el camino,
y la mayoría de las personas
fueron tratadas sólo con antidepresivos.
Desde entonces, se desarrolló
una visión más matizada
en el tratamiento de la depresión
y de sus causas.
No todas las personas con depresión
responden a los ISRS como el Prozac,
algunos responden mejor a fármacos
que actúan en otros neurotransmisores
o no responden a ningún medicamento.
Para muchos, una combinación
de psicoterapia y antidepresivos
es más efectiva que ambos por separado.
Tampoco podemos asegurar
por qué los antidepresivos
funcionan como lo hacen:
los niveles de las monoaminas cambian
a las pocas horas de tomar el fármaco,
pero los pacientes no sienten generalmente
el beneficio hasta semanas después.
Y cuando dejan de tomar los antidepresivos
algunos pacientes nunca vuelven a tener
depresión, mientras que otros recaen.
Ahora reconocemos que no sabemos
qué causa la depresión
o por qué los antidepresivos funcionan.
La teoría del desequilibrio químico
es la mejor explicación aunque incompleta,
No puede ser una coincidencia
que casi todos los antidepresivos
actúen sobre la serotonina,
lo que no implica que la deficiencia
de serotonina sea la causa de la depresión
Si eso suena raro,
piensa en un ejemplo más directo:
las cremas de esteroides pueden tratar
la erupción que causa la hiedra venenosa,
pero el hecho de que funcionen no implica
que la deficiencia de esteroides
sea la causa de la erupción.
Todavía hay mucho camino que recorrer
para entender esta enfermedad.
Por fortuna, mientras tanto,
tenemos medios efectivos para tratarla.